a couple years ago I had the opportunity
to travel to Beirut Lebanon to give a
talk it was an amazing experience I fell
in love with the city the culture the
heritage and most of all the people in
the course of my initial visit I was
introduced to a remarkable woman named
May el Khalil she's the founder of the
Beirut Marathon which has grown into the
largest running event in the entire
Middle East in 2015 May invited me to
run the marathon and I jumped on the
chance to return to Beirut
my impression of the middle-east have
been historically informed by mainstream
media as this very unsafe dangerous
corner of the world where tensions run
high and anything can happen anywhere at
any time what I found instead was this
incredibly beautiful dynamic city
overflowing with history and teeming
with warm and sophisticated people with
tremendous hope and resolve for a better
Lebanon sure the city is far more
threadbare worn or torn and strife
riddled than its pre Civil War Paris of
the Middle East heyday in the mid 1960s
but it remains this truly incredible
place pretty jet-lagged but I'm gonna go
out for a run
rundown we're in a cab where are we
going this is Isabel hi Isabel are you
running the marathon Sunday is about
what do you run it your first time me
too awesome
give me five so there's a lot of people
who've been asking me I got to beirut to
run a marathon you could run a marathon
anywhere like why they route the reason
that I'm here is that because I believe
that running can change the world I
believe that running can be a very
powerful instrument of peace
particularly in a place like Lebanon
where strife both political and
religious runs deep and has been going
on for a very long time for one day a
year we truly stand united and that's
when the marathon takes place an avid
runner herself Mei was inspired to start
the marathon after a near-fatal accident
left her in a coma countless surgeries
hospitalized for two years she would
never run again but the resolve from
this personal struggle motivated her to
give the gift of running to a city and a
country itself struggling to survive I
needed to dream big I needed something
to take me out of my pain and objective
to look forward to sunni-shia Armenian
Palestinian Egyptian Syrian Jordanian
American you name it 30 thousand runners
from all walks of opposing political
cultural and religious perspectives
congregate annually set aside their
differences and just broad
of literal moving piece procession and
when the gunfire went off this time it
was a signal to run in harmony
it is a platform for hope and
cooperation in an ever fragile and
unstable part of the world from Boston
to Beirut we stand as one after all
peacemaking is not a sprint it is more
of a marathon we begin in Lebanon where
the Islamic state has claimed
responsibility for one of the worst
attacks to hit Beirut in years panic and
confusion in Beirut as of last count has
killed at least 43 people wounded over
200 more that Douglas bombings to hit
the country just two days after the
Marathon violence returned to Beirut
when Isis attacked a neighborhood just
down the street from my hotel it was a
neighborhood I had walked through just a
few nights prior I was devastated Beirut
was no longer this distant foreign
unrelatable place that just pops up on
CNN from time to time it was real and
its people were my friends because
that's what travel does it breeds
empathy but when I reached out to my new
friends to make sure they were okay I
was met not with despair but with an
even firmer resolve to for unity
the echo may al-khalil making peace
truly is a marathon but it is a marathon
well worth
you